[Music]
down and I'm wasted
again and I just find myself another
bottle and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was Tred to
show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worse than man
I'm
wasted well I'm wasted
again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling Throne look
looking out of my kingdom of bone I LIF
the fire that burned it all down just so
I could [__] about my own us
CR I'm wasting
again and I just find myself another B
right
[Music]
in
cuz say the best part of see and downs
getting up I think I just don't give a
[__] close it up on these rocks I stay
where all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another Bo right
in cuz I'm
wasted I wasted
[Music]
again I just by myself another B and C
right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another b c
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding myself
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottom and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worst than man
I'm
wasted well I'm wasted
again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone I lift the
fire that burned it all down just so I
can BCT about my own usess
Crown I'm wasted
again and I'm just find myself another B
right
[Music]
in
CU say the best part being down getting
up I think I just don't give a [__]
close it up on these rocks I stay where
all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box
right
in cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again I just by myself another and right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another CW
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottom and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was Tred to
show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worse than man
I'm
wasted well I'm wasted
again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone I LIF the fire
that burned it all down just so I can
[__] about my own us
CR I'm wasting
again and I just find myself another B
right
[Music]
in
cuz say the best part L of being down
getting up I think I just don't give a
[__] close it up on these rocks I say
where all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another Bo right
in cuz I'm
wasted I wasted
again I just by myself another Bo and
right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another B CW
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just found myself another
bottle and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worse than man
I'm
wasting well I'm wasted
again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone I lift the
fire that burned it all down just so I
could BCT about my own usess
Crown I'm wasting
[Music]
again and I just find my another bot C
right
[Music]
in
cuz say the best part of being Down's
getting up I think I just don't give a
[__] close it up on these rocks I stay
where all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box
right
[Music]
in cuz I'm
wasted I wasted
again I just by myself another Bo and
right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another CW
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottle and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worst in I man
I'm
wasted well I'm wasted again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone i l the fire
that burned it all down just so I can
[__] about my own usess
Crown I'm wasting
again and I just find my another bot
right
[Music]
in
cuz say the best part of being Down's
getting up I think I just don't give a
[__] Clos it up on these rocks I stay
where all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box
right
[Music]
in cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again I just find myself another Bo and
right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another Bo CW
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottle and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all wor I'm man I'm
wasted well I'm wasted again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone I lit the fire
that burned it all down just so I could
[__] about my own us
Crown I'm wasting
[Music]
again and I'm just find my stop another
bottom right
[Music]
in
cuz say the part of being Down's getting
up I think I just don't give a [__] CL
it up on these rocks I say where all my
best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box CW
right
[Music]
in cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again I just found myself another B and
C right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just find myself another B and
CW right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottle and crawl right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all wored man I'm
wasted well I'm wasted again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne looking
out of my kingdom of bone I lit the fire
that burned it all down just so I can
[__] about my own us
Crown I'm wasting
again and I just find myself another B
CW right
[Music]
in
cuz they the best part of being Down's
getting up I think I just don't give a
[__] close it up on these rocks I stay
where all my best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box C
right
in cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another Bo and
C right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just find myself another C right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding my myself
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottle and craw right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worting I'm man
I'm
wasted well I'm wasted again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in sit upon my crumbling throne
looking out of my kingdom of bone I lit
the fire that burned it all down just so
I could [__] about my own usess
Crown I'm wasting
again and I'm just find myself another B
right
[Music]
in
cu best part of being Down's getting up
I think I just don't give a [__] close
it up on these rocks I say where all my
best friends are anyway I'm
wasted I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I find myself another box
right
[Music]
in cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just found myself another and
right
in yeah cuz I'm
wasted I'm wasted
again I just find myself another and cry
right
in I just find myself another bottle and
crawl right
[Music]
in
I look back on all my Wasted Years all
my trials tribulations and tears I never
seem to get up off the ground but I'm
the only one holding myself
down and I'm wasted
[Music]
again and I just find myself another
bottle and craw right
in I look back on all the women I've
known and all I've ever done was tried
to show the man they thought they found
inside of me but I'm all worse than I'm
man I'm
wasted well I'm wasted again
and I'll just find myself another box
and right
[Music]
in
n
[Music]
w
n
P there a bit of P ride there oh
yes guys follow us on all the social
media Instagram Twitter Facebook F
Foster constant kissing trigger pod
follow us all kill it already for come
on follow us follow us follow
[Music]
us not to be a it's chrristmas
take a from Santa
home the rest of us are doing our best
to beol so don't go looking like you
swallowed a
of
and your
[Music]
the to
be I'm slaying up to LA
not to
be c
n hello and welcome to the final
scheduled raw get your drinks out for
the lads come and have a sit down we're
going to have an absolutely belting time
we've got so much good news from around
the globe to talk about with you welcome
one welcome all it is raw there is so
much good news to talk about we're going
to be talking about Epstein we're going
to be talking about penal fractures
they're going to be talking about the
German they're back and they're doing it
better than ever so please make sure to
send in your super chats your paypals
and everything like that and we will
read them out also I'm going to stop
doing this also as
well ask me anything if you want me to
answer a question drop it here we're
going have a right good time I tell you
what you know I'm off my nut cuz I'm on
coke mate there you go it's Christmas
the like normally I try and eat healthy
you know low car blah blah blah for all
the good it does me but at the moment
the Train's gone off the [__] tracks
mate I'm drinking Coke I've just smashed
back a load of chocolate haven't been to
the gym this week got told by the uh
massage therapist that's how you know
you're doing well or you're getting old
that you've got a massage therapist paid
40 minutes for an ass massage
now you probably think that's sexual it
wasn't it's deeply painful cuz
apparently I'm in the early stages of
sciatica cheers 41 [__] years old and
I've got
sciatica but we've got so much good news
to talk about it's going to be
absolutely brilliant so with no further
Ado pull up the super chats iio and
let's see what we're dealing with don't
have any yet we don't have any yet you
mingy little
slags why you send any money you type
bastards it's Christmas and I'm here
trying to entertain you try and being
the operative word because how am I
going to entertain you without getting
paid you think Michael Jackson did it
without getting PA yeah not good not a
good example mate next time go with
something else I wonder if FF will do
the
No
No absolute filth I lived with him he is
was a vegetarian Anton he was a
vegetarian until he got together with
his mes and she knocked it out of him
good girl so there we go no I just like
look vegetables are fine but come on
mate V ganary [__] off as if the as if
January isn't difficult enough
unbelievable edot can put it up a little
bit because of the crack in the screen
thank you all right it's all very
let's see what he says he goes Merry
Christmas I'm so sad that this is the
last RW I will not I'm not sure who I'll
will give my [__] money to well it is
look here's here's a little bit of the
secret right we have got very long very
demanding schedules blah blah blah blah
blah but but whenever we can fit one in
we will always do our best s Mike thank
you right
next okay
FF oh it's 10 Canadians oh my God we're
from Canada so what are you asking for
FF what's on the menu for you this
Christmas uh what is on the menu so my
mom is obviously Venezuela never
mentioned it before and uh I have got
her six ayakas uh for other people from
a Latin American background you might
know them as tamales uh they are
absolutely [__]
disgusting just this is what this is
right so you get this meat and you get
like a raisin and an olive and a few
other spices that taste [__] rank you
get them in and you cover them in maze
it's like maze parcel you then wrap it
in banana leaves and then you boil it
and it is just as disgusting no that's
unfair it is worse than it sounds it is
if you like like AAS orales you're of NS
it is vile and in Venezuela what happens
is you go to someone's house CU
everybody makes ayakas and they go would
you like an aaka and I would say no
thank you I don't like ayakas and they
would go you have not DED my ayakas
they're delicious and then because
they're Latin women and they've never
heard the word no and if they have heard
the word no they don't give a [__] and
they keep pressing forward they would
then serve you they disgusting aaka so
you would just go from house to house
and cuz my mom obviously doesn't want to
be shown up by me I would then have to
eat the filthy thing so that's what you
eat in Venezuela a yakas absolutely
disgusting Al mes and if anybody says to
and there was one worse one than this
actually when they served you a fish
aaka and the woman who do serve me that
you know who your what your name is and
you deserve to be put actually you're
not alive anymore anyway but disgusting
Fisher
yakas I've got a question go on so I say
you had to eat those ayakas mhm with KK
yeah and three previous trigonometry
guests three previous trig guest who
would you
choose uh Doug douggy
Murray
billur and who would be the other buber
and oh so it' be douggy it would be
Bill uh and who else it would would it
be one more
person you know who it' be actually is a
bit of a left field one and because we
haven't we haven't released the episode
but he'd be great value Neil
Brennan there you go hands on I think
mine would I think starky would be on my
list that's a good shout David starky
yep Julie bindle the bindel yeah oh
she'd be great actually more about Rod
little as well he [__] me Rod little do
you know what I reckon we should get Rod
little back I'm not I'm being honest I
[__] do you remember when he said the
words [__] your mom to me in an
interview when I was explaining to her
how much explaining to him how much of a
fan she is of him and he went to me [__]
your mom
at that point Rod had had a few drinks
he's brilliant I think he's great value
Rod I think trigonometry peaked in that
moment to be honest yeah when Rod little
said to me [__] your mom yes mate that
was such good fun anyway send in who
your uh trigonometry Christmas party so
I so yeah we've got Elliot you go go for
it Pearl Davis [__] me all
right Theo Von Theo Von I mean Theo is
great I love Theo interesting
combination Paul Davis and Theo I mean
and then
third Nigel bigger and
Nigel so you've got a a man pretending
to be a
[__] and at a g a bonified one and an
Oxford dawn it's a perfect combo I mean
fair enough and you know what smartest
guy in the room would be Theo Von and
I'm not even joking the M I reckon Theo
Von is borderline a bit of a genius
going to be honest with you all right
did the cream work is it itchy no the
cream didn't work and it's still [__]
itchy next 20 nicker from ladyb with no
message finally a proper woman no
message okay Jamie B all right we a five
Canadians all right could you please put
the message up a little bit so I can
read it I caught Roar Just in Time while
it's on vacation worth it Merry
Christmas boys I'm going to miss this
love you both you hilarious [__] and
I should have mentioned constant is not
here cuz unfortunately he's still ill so
you need a real man to take care of
[__] business we've got a video
message from him oh you got video
message let's get it up get it up for
the
Lads hey guys sorry I couldn't be there
for the last ever scheduled uh
raw uh I've been spending a lot of time
either on the toilet or over it with
this uh Minge norovirus thing that my
wife and son have had as well so I
apologize I can't be there uh I know
you're in safe hands with Francis so
have a good one uh and don't be a m like
me and get the nor I mean he [__] me he
didn't look well Jesus I mean I he was
almost my color [__] mate get well soon
mate all right Mary okay Danish koner
yes I a [__] Danish hat of course I
have to wear it Merry Christmas triny
Father thank you very
much okay two to niika from vague an and
she says who you reckon is on the epsc
nons list well actually send your super
chats and your paypals and tell me who
you think is on the [__] nons list
and if you say prince Andrew that's like
going on pointless and when someone asks
you to name a Michael Jackson record you
say Billy Jean right so obviously Prince
Andrews are given who else is on the
nons list all right
next is douggy the sexiest guest male or
Fe oh sorry I have to apologize I'm off
the but it's 35 C can Rend I'm very
sorry yes is douy the sexiest guest male
or female you had on if not then
who that is a very good question Anton
sexiest guest who is it and why I'm
going to be I'm going to be
straightforward here I think I think
that would be um correct about douy you
think you'd be correct about douy can't
look Beyond douy you can't look beyond
douy all right Elliot come on
no comment no
comment unbelievable no comment you're
not even going to all right s fancy is
one of the ladies we've had
on uh sexiest
guest
um I don't know actually who is the
sexiest guest we have had
on
um I'm going to go for
I don't know actually the sexiest guess
that's a really good
doy it's Chris
Williamson
look that is beautiful you didn't hear
that Elliot just
went next thank
you okay
marus all the way from America he says
the rod leaves a little moment easily
the most memorable intrig history still
can believe those words tumbled out of
his mouth uh well if you knew anything
about Rod little mate it's not that
surprising that those words tumbled out
of his mouth I wouldn't describe it as
tumbled either no it was kind of like
projected into my face [__] your
mom
next okay Countess B oh Hello darling it
has been an absolute joy and a pleasure
hello count B is a big old fan of trig
she came to see my work in progress and
she came to see one of our live shows I
believe it was the um Andrew doily Doyle
one and she says I'm utterly devastated
about being the last schedule Ro and
Constantin isn't even here thank you
Francis for being an absolute legend for
Hold by holding the fort hope you all
have a lovely Christmas hope you have a
lovely one as well thank you very much
CEST B and that a move
and he says where the hell did I put my
hat here we go uh I can see that you're
woring the classic blue button up again
FF it's a staple of raw at this point
Merry Christmas well I couldn't do the
final one without that thank you very
much next will it still be a button up
after Christmas though probably not mate
more of an o overshirt yeah or either
that or I could be it'd be so tight it
basically be like a wet suit you know
and probably just as shiny because I've
worn it so many times okay five Canadian
dollars let's see what's going on here
following sve mes 50 bucks you you miss
calling for American flags in the chat
let's just do that are you're right I
did and my apologies s m let's get some
[__] Flags in the chat Let's Get Some
Guns in the chat let's get some freedom
in the chat for solve Mike my apologies
sve Mike we missed out on that one next
and thank you for bringing up that up
Choice a lucer Linden booms with a
€299 one Lush Merry Christmas for you
all thanks fres last night I loved your
oil stop something t-shirt stop oil you
bigger unbelievable have a good healthy
New Year KK and your family get well
soon well yeah thank you very much uh
Luchia but you've got but remember
darling that it's stop stop oil just
stop oil and they're trying to save the
world by getting us to stop using oil
what can we use as a replacement they
haven't answered that question yet but
there we
go okay mof says why not have the boys
on cam Crowder style they are on cam
we've got them on cam let's get you on
cam there you
go what no and that [__] that makes me
look even get rid of that camera I'm
starting to look there you go
I'm starting to look fat this is an
absolute disaster but it's too late and
I'm doubling down and then I can deal
with it all the other side of Christmas
thank you very much do you know what I
did when I got home yesterday boys yeah
you know what I did got a garlic bread
with cheese from the pizzeria it's it's
not going well I'm I'm I'm just I I've
just I'm I'm really [__] this up
that's bad isn't it getting home and
ordering in a garlic bread with pizza to
yourself that's nowhere near as bad as
today as well what do you mean today
nowhere near as bad with the chocolate
Hotel you've emptied out an entire
packet of what of chocolate buttons no I
didn't this is I had two you absolute
gaslighting little
[__] first stage is denial is
it that is ridiculous and
disgusting anywh who next you got [__]
ton on uh telegram oh we've got [__] ton
on telegram thank you very much so we've
got an absolute crap ton of messages on
telegram keep sending them in and we
were going to go from here so the first
one
is uh was Scrooge and oron okay Steve
Richardson and he asks was scrog a
northerner uh probably mate no because
he had money okay
here we go this is from Mr Steve 170 I
had a rabbit pie a couple of days ago it
was delicious we really should eat
rabbit rabbit more the fur makes
wonderfully
soft and uh just saying it was very nice
there we go rabbit pie everybody Mar got
garbage he says I need to cook you
sinful stuff if Tomales were good South
America wouldn't be a mess quite the
tomal are absolutely uh disgraceful next
Farley Ross raw is so important to me
you help me train for the London
Marathon I've spent hours listening to
your shite out there there's no other
show like this anywhere please keep
doing them we are going to carry on
doing them in an infrequent manner
Farley Ross but you're right I love
doing them they're great fun and I can't
believe that people pay attention to
this NP stuff this nonsense
last stukin with the 10 Canadians oh my
God it's Jordan Peterson who does a rap
at the end of raar inquiring bigots want
to know I don't actually know I we
should find out it's incredible he is a
very talented
man and Matt Shaw with a hundred
Singaporean dollars let's get some
singaporeans Flags in the chat let's get
some trans Flags in the chat he's a big
fan of PR Patel so let's get some
British flags in the chat for my office
secret santa my trans Bride on brand
produced a USB of videos of her
tributing photos of all my 57 colleagues
huge Jeffer the O the office diversity
hire objected to her stupid woke face
being covered in grade a gender fluid
wonderful let's do it in 2024 # ladyboys
for
Israel marvelous but if you knew
anything lady boy are much more popular
in Iran mat sure but thank you Matt Shaw
you're a gentleman okay so Ian what
what's his surname vult oh Italian
meaningful voice uh predictions for 2024
label will use a UK election will lose a
UK election Trump wins US election a
surprise Hunter Biden wakes up with
Dylan Mulaney I don't think that Hunter
B I don't listen you've got to be honest
I don't think there's any other I don't
think Hunter would do that I think
Hunter knows what a woman is all right
but that was a great joke well done
labor will lose in the UK election I
don't think so in I think uh label will
get him with a vastly reduced majority
with the lib Dems is my prediction what
do I know and it's a long way away thank
you just stop doy couldn't agree with
you more classic pun thank you very much
that's it that is it so let's just check
I will need to check to see if we have
any pay Palios and there better be some
pay Palios otherwise there's going to be
problems okay let's see if you've got
I'm I'm looking to see oh we've received
some money good so first one is uh from
Jenna and there is no message so thank
you Jenna we really do appreciate that
okay and let's see what the other one is
uh this is from
Joyce thank you Joyce and she says
uh I can't afford the Canadian okay all
right so this is Joyce and she's from
Canada and she goes I can't afford this
Canadian quadruple tax but here's a
worldd deserved end of the year bonus
and she sent in I think probably
6284 which I think is 100 Canadian
dollars so could everybody please let's
put some people it's with thank you
let's put some Canadians and flags in
the chat let's put some people of color
in the chat like your prime minister and
let's put some Jordan Peterson in the
chat thank you very much Joyce you are a
mench sue juice yes with the S African R
and he says January is World conward
month well done couldn't agree with you
more Joseph Claudia van thank you so
much for a wonderfully funny Year Merry
Christmas FF and a happy New Year thank
you very much Claudia really do
appreciate thanks for coming to the gigs
and for supporting you're a diamond so
on high like Eagle he says shabbat
shalom please offer a gem kicking gam
Camp to to KK I don't know why I'm
talking like this while we continue to
pray for KK and his
family KK FF Elliot and Anton you all
stay strong and stay healthy and strong
for
2024 what let's do it o KK mate [__]
man up
son
there we go thank you very much okay Rod
here's a mini FIV to for FF to replace a
bag of chocolate buttons you're a good
man
Rod okay Amy vows all right
Amy let's do it cheers uff for carrying
raw carrying on with Roy like the legend
you are also happy to see an Anon and
ell's beautiful face says feel better KK
I'm wishing you all a very happy
Christmas and New Year thank you very
much Amy you know Amy is a lady of class
and culture cuz I bumped into Amy and a
kebab
shop thanks Amy darling really do
appreciate it Elliot can we just check
how much Amy sent please just make sure
oh and we deserve some American flags in
the chat let's have some American flags
in the chat let's have some guns let's
have some Freedom let's have some
demented old men in the chat thank you
very much Amy you've got one more on
telegram there is one more on telegram
thank you so much to all the beautiful
bigots who've been contributing tonight
we really do appreciate it we have one
more let's see who it's from it is from
Fryman kikoman Thanks for the Memories
FF and sick KK it's been a great it's
been a great bigoted few years we did Co
the Tory party Antics and the demise of
the country together yes we went through
it well I mean there have been a lot of
memories doing this one Anton what do
you think about Everton's good run there
you
go I just I I predicted it from as soon
as the it was rumored that we were going
to get 10 points taken off us I said
take the 10 points off us cuz we're not
going to win anything anyway this season
take the 10 Point offo it'll Galvanize
the players bring the players the fans
the board together like they've needed
for the last 30 years and that's looks
that looks like um what's happened to be
honest so I'm very pleased was that too
much no it's not too much mate there you
go so he's very happy although there are
rumors are going to take even more
points of him but let's not focus on
that actually there is a picture of me
here's a video of me and Anton when we
live together Elliot is someone with a
little dog this is me and an on when we
were living together we were best mates
and every day was wonderful here we go
you know a lot of people ask me uh after
a long day of VoiceOver or writing or
doing all those creative things that I
do um how do I relax well like many
other Americans uh I come home and I I
pet my dog you see petting the dog is
one of the most relaxing things you can
possibly do it releases a hormone
oxytocin which reduces stress also it
lowers your heart rate and it lowers
your blood pressure plus people who pet
their dogs are five times more likely to
live longer than people who just have
cats plus the dogs like it so much and
it's a nice bonding
experience that's right daddy little boy
daddy's little boy daddy's little boy
that's
right
so there we go there was me and Anton
when we used to live together because
during the pandemic we used to do this
from our flat we did it for two years
and we well we asked to leave the first
flat then we got kicked out of the
second flat so we've been kicked out of
a lot of places and I was having a
conversation with KK actually he went
Francis have you ever thought that this
might not be about them but it just
might be about you cuz you've been
fighting kicked out of a lot of places
and I have and I've just had terrible up
with people they're absolute [__]
[__] any who right inin with a 20
nicker thank you insain to commemorate
the last scheduled Ross do uh do a nonat
who's a non of the Year also KK stops
slacking off who so uh let's okay who's
a non of the Year oh scoffield you think
scoffield was it scoffield or was it
Hugh Edwards no because Hugh Edwards he
was 17 although although the boy did
send him sexual content of himself which
me is illegal in this country and
technically classed as a minor so Hugh
Edwards let's just call alleged
nons I think it that was a non Story of
the Year I know scoffield was big but it
wasn't as big as Hugh Edwards Hugh
Edwards Hugh Edwards had the like the
the the big reveal yeah he did like the
who done it yeah it was massive it was a
beautiful do you know what you couldn't
write it really do you know what and I'm
not I did a video about this but it's
absolutely true it brought the country
together mate yeah honestly people have
been at each other's throat brexit Trump
covid you know war in Ukraine at that
point everybody was at each other's
throats and you know what we just sat
down and during that beautiful time
where there was a BBC non
and no one knew who he was and which was
just it was just beautiful it was like
the The Who shop Phil Mitchell for 2023
exactly or who shot Jr if you're
American it was wonderful we all
wondered who it was the rumors and they
you know one by one the BBC presenters
had to come out and announce that they
weren't announ cuz that's the caliber of
the institution now where you actually
have to come out and say you're not a
sex offender um I still think scoffield
was better you really
yeah
why just the way he drew from his Vape
during the interview Midway through have
you seen that clip
no the way he did it it was only a nons
would draw from a vape like that it was
like one those little elf bars that
13year olds have in secondary school yep
I mean beautiful and that's a great
thing about Britain is that we've just
got such a long and Noble history of
noning it's beautiful it's beautiful
it's what makes us who we are thank you
very much okay uh so let's call I don't
know what we're going to do we're going
to do a hat because you're a Euro okay
it's uh I don't know where you're from
Ry vsn jumping the Cure of faithful raw
fans wishing you a lovely Christmas #
fat and proud # food galaw that sounds
great mate
wonderful
okay Joseph y with a 35 c African rand
FF when are you doing your part to fight
the population depopulation
agenda me and Anton are going to have a
surrogate very
soon
next how many kilos will be the chi skma
yes wish with the Dutch hat it goes how
many kilos would be the Christmas damage
oh M it's it's off the at this point
I've just said [__] it I've said
absolutely [__] it it's it's an absolute
car crash at the moment my life I'm here
it's what 25 to 25 to8 and I'm just
smashing back a Coke Zero I've never had
one of these before there is cancer in a
can and I'm a smash it back and I
couldn't give a [__] if it's terrible
thank
you okay Jack Masashi KK is faking being
sick to get time off over the holidays
such a classic move that it should be on
the citizenship
exam not my words Jack's words now he's
actually very sick look at that video he
looked awful okay fralia you're you're
an Italian you're an Italian Viking yeah
uh we miss a regular Rose but excited
for what 2024 has in store for trick
Stella work on the linan interview by
the way merry Christmas all of you from
me and Mr frali if you haven't seen the
crime linan and what are you doing you
mingy little slag it is incredible it is
an
absolutely wonderful interview thank you
very much
fali okay Mata with a 20
singaporeans my moment of the year was
pretty Patel bouncing round the Downing
Street Garden covering Wilfred Johnson
spacehopper with the tidal flow of the
of the what does that see patriotic doll
the Patriotic doll from between from
between her powerful brex City thighs #
spicy brown girl
flavor
mate let's just read that again Wilford
Johnson spacehopper with the tidal flow
over her patriotic doll from beneath her
powerful brex City
thighs I tell you what mate that
is that is either the magic or the
degeneracy of the internet maybe in the
words of a great man a little bit of
both thank you Matt Shaw
next one more on Telegram and we've got
one more on the tegio let's
see let's see what they are having to
say the
audience and it is from nud nudge wink
wink norovirus is related to poor
hygiene KK ordered a dirty Donna from
keag King where Abdul never washes his
hands after a piss typical bloke there
we go and one more above it and one more
above it thank you so much let's see
what we've got we got one more above
it uh F that's F Mo keik man we did that
one they said we missed it well fro keep
C man no we we did that one we did that
one indeed oh so Paul D with a f thank
you very much Paul really appreciate it
is that the last one y okay let's get
you know what we've been talking about
nonsense let's get up a great man over
170 of of Jeffrey Epstein's high-profile
Associates will be named in court
documents set to be unsealed in the
first days of
2024 a judge has ruled to unseal
documents that would name
177 uh who are Epstein's friends
recruiters and victims within the coming
weeks the material is related to to a
defamation case brought by Prince
Andrew's accuser Virginia Roberts now
called Virginia Gaffrey in New York
against EP steams Madam Jizzy Maxwell
the hundreds of files will shed new
light on The Late Financial sex
trafficking operation and his network of
influence uh dozens of Jeffrey Epstein's
high-profile Associates are in for a New
York surprise or New Year surprise as
they will be named in court documents
said to be released
in the final or the first days of 2024
the ped's powerful friends is set to be
exposed as part of a vast unsealing that
a judge ordered on Monday will take
place in 14 days that will take the
release date to January the 1st but as
that is a holiday it is likely the files
be made public the following day uh some
177 people will be identified across
hundreds of files which says new light
on The Late financiers sex trafficking
operation and his network of influence
there he is look at the sexy [__] do
you know what for aedo he's a
good-looking
bloke well he weren badl looking what do
we reckon would you Anton would you
shake Jeffrey
Epstein not this is how I imagined my
first appearance on on Raw to to go to
be honest and I don't think he'd have a
choice would he no he might look an
Anton could definitely take him in the
in the physical department so would you
sh Jeffrey are we are we pursuing the
question yeah yeah we're pursuing the
question um I'm going to say no I'm
going to choose now g g all right Elliot
would you shake Jeffrey Epstein no all
right would
you I mean look think about this it'd
make a hell of a
story imagine you're at a party and
someone Rises Jeffrey epon you went
[__] him in the ass actually
tell me that that is not a story that
you want to hear so you do it for free
mate I could get back on Rogan with that
story Joe would have me back on JRE in a
Flash if I [__] Epstein up the ass I'm
telling you that in fact I'd do all of
them Lex would have me on Diary of a CEO
and they'd all want to hear about the
time I took Jeffrey Epstein up the ass
would you rather take Jeffrey Epstein up
the ass or Michael Jackson
oh
Epstein because no one really like with
Michael it's contentious plus the
reality is everybody loves Michael
Jackson and no one likes a snitch all
right shag Mario void yeah
MJ
Epstein and Philip
scoffield avoid Philip scoffield clearly
the least interesting out of all of
those three men that's not even a
question
okay shag Jeffrey
Epstein marry Michael Jackson because I
mean that's that's another JRE interview
right there I was married to Michael
Jackson and I shagged Jeffrey epine up
the ass you wouldn't be able to do one
podcast with that you'd need to do you
know what I mean where would the MJ
wedding be if you married him what would
what would sort of the ceremony be
ceremony by the time I married him he
was quite quite clearly way past his
best both mentally and physically
because he'd be marrying me
overage so that being the case I
reckon I reckon cuden is probably all he
could afford at that
point yeah definitely C him okay uh the
M the material is related to a
defamation case brought by Prince
Andrew's accuser Virginia Roberts in New
York against Epstein's Madam uh Jizzy
Maxwell Robert sued Maxwell for
defamation in 2016 and when the and
while the case was settled the Miami
Herald which published a bombshell
expose of Epstein that led to his arrest
in 2019 said to Su to get the documents
made public some of the do some of the
of the do the John do sorry are
identified in the ruling through links
to interviews they have given to the
media which the judge cited as a reason
why they should not stay private they
include the housekeepers on Epstein's
private island in the Caribbean where
some of the worst abuse that he
perpetrated was carried out in her
ruling judge presca gave 14 days I mean
she's going to die there's no way she's
getting for for that uh for any those
who objected to their documents being
made public to object after which they
would be unsealed there will be
documents about one of Prince Andrew's
accusers who claimed he fondled her
breast at EP New York Mansion there will
also be material about Haley Robson who
was named as a recruiter and police
files of Epstein's original
investigation 2006 in pal speech
although she has more recently claimed
she was a victim too the file uh the the
finally suggest some documents will
relate to Jean Luke Brunell a French
model Scout he was a very famous nons
who was Clos to epin and allegedly
abused many young women uh Brunell
hanged himself what a coinci incident in
a Paris prison cell in 2022 while
awaiting trial on a slew of sex charges
the documents in the case have been
released on a rolling basis since 2019
when the first batch were made public
days before epin also hanged himself I
mean so many coincidences in prison
whilst awaiting trials on sex
trafficking charges among the
revelations in previous batches of
documents were emails between Andrew and
Epstein in 2015 when Roberts made
allegations about him the batch of 177
do is a final group and includes many
who were notified by the court but not
but did not object to documents with
their name on them being made public the
material is likely to include
depositions emails legal documents and
other material not previously made
public those three and four appear to be
miles and Kathy Alexander a South
African couple who manages who managed
little St James again Little
James 's private island in the Caribbean
for years judge Presa cited a 2011
interview the couple gave to the Daily
Mail as one of their reasons their name
should be made public in the interview
the couple claimed that it was not their
place to judge other people even though
they suspected some of the gos on the
island were
young Grim absolutely grim and there's V
Victoria Roberts or Guffy as she is now
known with prince Andrew it's got no
recollection of why that of where that
picture was taken what a massive
surprise keep
scrolling anyway so there we
go absolute nons stre of the highest
order there I cannot believe that there
are going to be any significant people
released on that list apart from prince
Andrew and that's because there's no
protecting him anymore because the man
is clearly a [__] and he's basically
wrecked his own life and career all
right it's Hobie camelon everybody hey
Hobie how you doing Merry Christmas
everyone thanks for a wonderful year and
blessings for an amazing 24 2024 Rory
never disappoints God bless you Kobe
let's have some American flags let's
have some some guns in the chat let's
have freedom in the chat for Colby
Hamilton Rod he's a f for ff's comom f
found he's going to need a family pack
thanks mate
massive okay yes
so Joseph yes with the 35 sou afan R he
says Elliot had a tough time with his
first few RWS look uh now Anton he here
to help him out to keep him from getting
do 10
points okay thank you very
much thanks for the roar all right
that's Canadians it's Jordan Peterson
you're saying thank you for the Roar and
I'm saying thank you for the
message uh FIV and this is from Mish
listen to the end of Raw rap on two
times speed it slaps good good bye and
God bless raw we hardly knew you well
thank you so much Mikes look it's been
we will continue to do them and uh
Elliot can you put them for higher up
please the messages because yeah thank
you we're all going to need to be around
that level
now it's been it's been a pleasure man
we there have been some amazing times on
the show um we really have the show has
been through so many different
iterations and in its life um and look
one of my favorite times was during the
pandemic when we were doing RWS and they
were just absolutely banging and so much
fun thank you very
much rabbit pie question for Anon was
from Mr Steve how do you think Elliot is
doing your old role please just donate
this money equally between Anton and
Elliot he's doing really well I wish I
had something funny to say say um but
he's he's taking it on another another
level which is what we all thought he'd
do got to say something funny Francis
what awesome answer G yeah absolute
disgrace anyway thank you very much
that's it that is it
look here's the thing over Christmas
you've got to take it seriously do you
know what I mean you got to take it
seriously cuz things happened during
Christmas tragedies because drink and
whatever else so it's important you look
after your and we're going to talk about
very serious
topic right now during Christmas have a
look at this this is serious guys this
is what goes on during
Christmas risk of pile fractures Rises a
Christmas doctors find researchers
suspect Euphoria and intimacy of season
may be behind spiking cases it may be
the season of loving and giving but
doctors have warned against embracing
this Spirit too
enthusiastically at least where sexual
relations are concerned they have
discovered that the Christmas period is
associated with a significant in
significantly increased risk of penol
fractures a medical emergency in which
the erection producing regions of the
penis snap usually as a result of
forceful bending oh during over
enthusiast Astic sexual
intercourse uh this injury tends to
occur during wild sex particularly in
positions where you're not in direct
direct eye contact with your partner you
filthy
monkeys uh such as reverse
cgo said Dr Nicholas per perides of
course he's [__] Greek Dirty Bastard
a urologist at the ludvig maximilan
University of Munich who led the
research yeah you could have just left
it with you're not looking at your
partner you didn't have to specify what
your favorite [__] sexual position is
not only and he's double dirty because
not only is he Greek he's a Greek living
in Germany
filthy uh the fractures are often
heralded by an audible crack followed by
severe pain rapid loss of erection well
can't of take that as a given and severe
swelling and bruising
uh when uh patients present to their
doctor their penis often looks like an
eggplant per perid said suspecting the
intimacy and Euphoria of the festive
season might be a risk factor for this
type of injury pidis and his colleagues
examined Hospital data for
3,421 men who suffer who suffered penal
fractures in Germany between 2005 and
2021 somebody do the ma 3,421 div
divided by
16 the study the first to explore
seasonal patterns for this type of
injury found that such injuries were
indeed more common over Christmas in
fact if every day was like Christmas 43%
more Peno fractures would have occurred
in Germany from 2005 on the research
which is published in the British
Journal for Urology International Kraken
read Harley recommend you check it out
also found the risk increased at
weekends and over the summer holidays
however New Year's Eve was not
associated with an increased incident of
penis injuries you know why because New
Year's Eve is an overrated piece of [__]
I I don't I don't know a single person
who likes New Year's Eve it is so
overrated it is
ridiculous it would be interesting to
see data from other countries but in
Germany Christmas week is what widely
celebrated while New Year's Eve tends to
be a bit quieter see what I mean
[__] uh Hospital admissions for penal
fractures remained relatively consistent
during the covid-19 pandemic say this is
a CO material we were talking about uh
including during lockdown periods the
average age for sustaining such injuries
was 42 how old are you Francis [__] off
most penol fractures occur in
unconventional or sexual scenarios such
as during extramarital Affairs or when
do or when sex is performed in unusual
locations not going to happen to me mate
CU I don't have sex adding that such
scenarios were possibly more likely when
men were approaching
midlife have you ever done that
Anton bit of the outside Nookie I'm not
trained for this that's yes he advised
couple to be aware of the risk of injury
and exercise caution in the runup to
Christmas if it does happen you should
present to your doctor as an absolute
emergency because if you are not treated
you could suffer long-term
complications [__] me bo uh health and
safety Chris common chrisps so penol
fraes are not the only thing associated
with the festive season Christmas trees
all right all right we can get it what
else OT scroll down past Christmas trees
fairy
lights turkey
trauma champagne Corks And swallowed
bobles let's see anything else heart
disease that'll be me Santa injuries
that'll probably be me thank
you there we go right let's can through
your paypals and your super
chats uh s Joe good to see you coming
off silly dieting and becoming the size
of a Russian Bear pity KK is in no shape
to fight you Merry eating Christmas
thank you very much soj Jo couple more
on telegram we've got a couple more on
telegram y let's see fantastic
stuff unre message we've only got one
unre message uh yes Joseph yes in with
the 35 can rent and he said D about the
naughty list absolutely we have got
Palio it's Aid V bash last raw last
paypals but all the promised laws did
convince me to John Lal thank you very
much Arvid Von Brash we really really
really do appreciate it so Elliot I
think we've got time for one more
article and we have done the little
voice so bring up the next
article with the Germans returning to
being
German I'm looking forward to this here
we go hard right afd wins K election in
East Germany and nobody is worried least
theoy Jordan alternative for Germany
party sees its biggest Victory yet as
budget crisis boosts populist the
right-wing populist alternative for
Germany afd party has won the race for
the keep sing please uh for the mayale
Mor ality May mayor mayor anyway can't
don't know what that word is uh of a
large town on the outskirts of Dron I
think it's the Mayoral race basically
it's biggest Victory yet in a series of
steady advances at local levels the
resulting p a town of 40,000 people in
the heart of East German wine country
may be a foraste of the months ahead
with the afd currently leading the
polling for three state elections to be
held across the region next year as the
majority of the local elections split
between two rival parties of the center
right Tim lochner and Mara Carpenter
running for the FD needed only
38.5% of the vote to be to become P
orbert Boer
me or head of the municipal
Administration it is the first time the
party secured a post of this kind but
follows similar breakthroughs on a
smaller scale in raan jnet near leig and
sonberg on the border between thuringia
and Bavaria in Saxony the state in which
perer is located the afd is now pulling
at
35% even though the state branch of
Germany's domestic Security Agency
officially classified the regional
branch of the party as evidently
rightwing extremist only a month ago so
that's comforting so we've got uh we've
got some we've got our boys kicking off
uh going to marches demanding that the
uding get
uh yeah let's just put eliminated and
now we've got these boys in Germany it's
good times yor arban the afd leader in
Saxony said the male election had proved
that his party was capable of entering
government we want to win here in Saxony
we want to win by a clear margin we want
to get to 40% it is what the forward
would
want uh lner 53 a well personality in
the town well there's a euphemism
technically ran as an independent but
aligned himself with the afd and the
part party's electoral electoral
Machinery behind him he campaigned Prim
primarily with promises to lead a more
responsive and downto Earth municipal
government pledging to give up the
mayor's grace and favor car and to
personally test every member of
administrative staff for
loyalty that sounds a bit s Minister
mate doesn't it mate I mean look I'm all
for free speech and everybody having a
chance to you know and free and fair
elections all the rest of
it I'm going to be honest with you these
boys rediscovering a bit of the Old
National
collectivism not not a
fan especially when they say we're going
to test you for loyalty oh we've already
done this one IIA thanks mate okay
gam and gam and cam to my
fiance about me being a
bigot all right listen Colin spur right
[__] pay attention right this is
training for
marriage listen he's a bigger [__]
accept
it anyway thank you all right yoseph
yassen with a 35 cfd if he can
rent may you all live long and prosper
thank you very
much okay here is can you put it up
please uh thank you OT thank you here is
a f for Elliot's quiff gel fund thank
you
Rod uh even Harden please even harder
there's a Freudian slip thank you Elliot
even higher all right Singaporean
dollars Matt Shaw craze haridan trying
to snap our reproductive organs show
that men are under attack ignore anti
fallous maniacs and enjoy lady boys who
look after their special organs instead
HH dignity couldn't put it better myself
mat sure thank you very much lady sastro
just to wish all the big a wonderful
Christmas looking forward to the new
trick but will miss rooll see you in the
new year thank you very much cilia lady
sarcast okay so on high like Eagle thank
you to all mods indeed Merry Christmas
and future new year at mof at J's pal
Sophie the BL and Marco at gabbage thank
you for the
banter that's it that is it so we've got
a couple of minutes to go so before we
do that before we sign off I want to say
to each and every single one of you who
has watched who has supported who has
listened who has shared content who has
sent money if you haven't sent money why
the [__] have you not sent money you I'm
doing this out of goodness Amar
not [__] takes a piss no I'm
joking thank you to every single last
one of you we genuinely wouldn't be able
to do the show without you we wouldn't
be able to transform the show we
wouldn't be able to make the show what
it is we wouldn't be able to take the
show from a above a smelly Pub in in
Angel isington to where it is now in
this studio without all of your
incredible support thank you so much to
each and every single one of you I hope
you have a wonderful restful Christmas I
hope you have a nice one if it's you're
going to have a bit of a tough one at
Christmas just bear in mind no one's
honest about Christmas everyone has a
[__] R over Christmas it'll be fine
have a wonderful New Year
cheers Giza thanks to you wolf really
appreciate me any other super chats
before we go no that's it let's it let's
just double check that we have no pay
Palios no we don't so to each and every
single one of you thank you for watching
the show thank you for being part of the
journey thank you for tuning in when we
were going through the hellscape of the
pandemic you are the ogs I love you
thank you very
much have a belter see you on the other
side see you later everyone this is this
is an ending but it's also you
completely [__] that up I built it
beautifully it was beautiful it built it
built it built I then injected a moment
of real emotion into it and then he was
they on the point of tears and then you
come in like my autistic little brother
go yeah so we've just really enjoyed it
thank you I've been waiting 5 years to
say that what what I say then well what
did you say he had a script he has a
script here on his notepad right okay
have you got a script I just said I was
just I just wanted to say this is an
ending but it's it's the beginning of a
of a lot of you know of a whole new era
for trigonometry so stick with us
exactly just I would say that was great
on the
pad on the pad that was great it was a
lovely thought but he just anyway it was
similar to your comedy set last week
wasn't it what that's harsh
that's we're technically over now and
you bring that
in I mean that is that is that is that's
a low blow mate it's a low blow I'm up
here on my own mate I'm me to tell how
many people we got watching uh
1,000 and this is how they respond what
a disgrace thank you so much to each and
every one of you have a belter good
night
if you like British politics with a bit
of Comedy some quality great
conversations of honesty get to hear the
thoughts of the silent majority the San
all this woke [__] watch trigonometry
six pants of Stella smoke a pack of
salmon Fran feriz the true essence of a
gam it's time to call the big boys get
on Steve Bannon cuz you got to push back
the claws of the red dragon I feel that
Brendon O'Neill was the real deal he's
like morphus and the Matrix giving out
these red pills but just take one not
the whole bottle that's what Michael Mal
said said and a man's a role model just
watch your last interview with David
Stark he's a gateway drug got me feeling
like a Nazi that's what these labor
activist every you think putting too
much soy milk in the teas that they
drink as for lawence Fox they try to put
him in a box and say his views are
problematic and really should just be
doxed this maners has to stop the whole
Council culture is a mess the
progressive left the swarming LS and
vultures half Venezuelan other half
holigan you voted to remain in a
European Union because you're good
people having a laugh like when Andre
tweet Tiana McGrath I see you're on a
path to hopefully make some money how
about once a month bringing back Douglas
Murray looking like a thirst tra and I
ain't even gay dude W comedy is like
Cosby with a qu sending me to sleep
while I'm sitting in my seat surrounded
by a sea of virtue signaling sheep he's
ow Jones types and his social justice
mobs and they won't be satisfied until
they take away your jobs looking down on
the white working class like snobs while
they praying at the pool pit of
progressive Gods so [__] your think
tanks in your left leaning Quang go you
reach Peak wanks so I'm off for Rando
Constantine kissing my favorite Jewish
Nazi outright Russian propping up the
patriarchy so like And subscribe to the
YouTube channel if you're sick to the
back tee for question times panel I'm
out by Russian book by comrade
Constantine it will cause political
polarization and bring down vestern
democracy